in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Renee
and Marissa are with us hey guys how are
you doing better than I deserve welcome
it's good to have you where do you live
there Consequences New Mexico there you
go
awesome very neat and you came all the
way to Nashville Tennessee to do your
debt free scream yes well we're very
very proud of you guys how much debt
have you paid off it was just under 96
thousand dollars and about 22 months 96
thousand bucks in 22 months that's
pretty amazing
what was your range of income during
that time oh we started about 95 and
ended up okay very cool what are you to
do for a living I'm a wildlife biologist
mm-hmm I'm a high school teacher very
cool like what are you teaching a high
school math ah
loved math can you imagine dave ramsey
liking math there you go so very fun so
what kind of debt was the 96 thousand
our house you're paid off your house we
did I'm looking at where people you guys
are awesome thank you way to go it feels
weird I'll bet what's this house worth
last we had it appraised is about 140
but we had some improvements done so
maybe 145 yeah very nice and his dead
gun paid for you on it
absolutely absolutely amazing so tell me
the story what happened 22 months ago
that got you guys fired up where you
blow through 96 brand in under two years
it's all the math teacher it's the math
teacher yeah well I was we had just
started I had just started teaching in
my friend Audriana and Nathan who were
also teachers invited us to go to a
financial class which I didn't know what
it was all about and we happened to be
at their church for a 4-h club meeting
and I saw the parents get up and leave
during the club meeting and so I
followed them and I saw adrionna like
hey what are you doing she's like I
forgot to tell you she'd forgot to tell
me that the class that started a week
prior so she gave me a box
i sat down and he said well you go with
listen and I'll go watch the boys and
you know those heel marks that you
always talk about I had the deepest
longest heel marks going into that class
of anybody how bad okay so now yeah I'm
kind of the cheerleader he went on Nate
went out first and tried to get him to
come into the class then I'd Rihanna
went out tried to get him the class
finally Nate went out again and finally
got him to come in he sat like this the
whole time very grouchy the second time
he sat up a little straighter the next
time he pulled the book away from me and
started filling in the blanks oh and a
convert now I think a worse nerd than I
am when it comes to the finances cuz I
was the spreadsheet Queen with about
nine different tabs on my Excel
spreadsheet so that that's a great story
I love that so Renee tell me what was
going through your mind what was your
resistance to going I know what mine
would have been I would have been just
like you but what was yours well I mean
with me it was just you know she had
always done bills and everything else I
mean she has a degree in economics and
I'm like yeah you take care of that I
didn't like it I didn't want to do you
know the budget or anything like that
that was you know I'd left it all to her
and didn't realize that I was putting a
stress and burden on her until we went
to the class and sure that really opened
my eyes but what was the thing with the
arms crossed I mean you didn't want to
be in there I didn't I just I thought
you know that stuff that she's good I
don't even want to be here waste of my
time I wanna do it okay and then what
started happening in your mind that by
the third class you took the book away
from her
well it just started making sense I mean
it was everything that you were talking
about in the class I mean it just it
started clicking with me like wow that
that makes a whole lot of sense maybe we
should look into this more and you know
as we practiced you know for the week
we'd go to the class and practice that
for the week
it just started making more and more
sense to me and it started getting
momentum and then you know we got really
intentional with everything and it was
just amazing that the difference it made
and how we were approaching our finances
and saving and everything else is
amazing so Marisa how long you guys been
married 18 years Wow and
two years ago things changed for the
better much yes absolutely
it changed a great deal he helped with
the budget of course when I was hard to
let go of my spreadsheets so for the
first three or four months we tried to
do it with my spreadsheets and he didn't
understand it so we needed a master's
degree when we finally went to the every
dollar app that was a huge blessing okay
much easier because it does it does the
work like the spreadsheets do but it's
easier to understand oh okay very cool
very cool
so I mean your your desire it sounds
like Marissa was to get some of the
weight of making all the decisions off
of you and you start making them with
your husband is that a big change now
yeah we talked about everything we did
about big purchases prior but it was all
the little things because if I made up
my error on my spreadsheet you know
transposed a number or whatever
I couldn't sometimes I wouldn't see it
so it was nice to have him back me up
wrong very cool good anthony question I
got one question I met you kids earlier
outside and I have a question as a
father and mother and even as a school
teacher which thank you so much for
serving our young people I love y'all so
much why would you say can you just say
throughout this what have you learned
why is it important for parents to teach
their kids about money you all are debt
free so it's like why should parents now
start jumping in and really teaching
their kids about being debt-free
well that's thing for for me I mean it's
knowing what we went through when we
first got married and you know going
from paycheck to paycheck we'd balance
the checkbook and that'd be 10 cents
left for two weeks and were like wow
okay I guess we're gonna sit home and
watch the grass grow or something so you
know being able to teach that to them
and early on where they can where they
can start learning and doing the right
things from the beginning and not get
into those situations for me I think
that's that's huge to get them and and
give them that head start
yeah and for my students it's also you
know they're a lot of times their
parents don't teach them or they don't
know what to teach them and so
a class I also teach your foundations
thank you you're welcome
I thought five classes through your
class so far I just completed my third
year teaching and so sending off those
seniors that are graduating you know
often to the real world with those as
for rewarding as a math teacher it's
fantastic so what are your kids names
and ages addresses 13 Miguel will be 11
next month and Joaquin is 9
all right and they've been practicing
their debt free screen yes the detriment
of our eardrums all the way from New
Mexico I love it all right Renea Marissa
and the guys from Truth or Consequences
New Mexico $96,000 paid off if you're
watching on YouTube or you're watching
on the app you're looking at weird
people paid for 22 months they did this
making 95 to 107 you guys are heroes hey
we're going to give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book signed retire inspired
because that's the next step in your
journey you've got the first part of the
story done let's turn to chapter 2 and
keep going and count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
nothing like three boys to do a good
debt free scream hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common